[Music]
[Applause]
everybody my name is ben sports i played
the voice of sonic the hedgehog in the
sonic the hedgehog movies thank you
that's very kind thank you very much uh
and i just wanted to say thank you so
much for supporting our movie also thank
you very much for the note about sonic's
legs and teeth in our original trailer
then no for real that's a good note
that's a good note i'm really happy that
worked out we needed that we really
needed that
the good news is so many of you loved
our first movie that we got to make a
sequel and today yes
video game movies come on
yes
sure two other people at the end
today
i brought with me the trailer
to that sequel
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean this is you can
this isn't like the real trailer this is
a blank dvd for effect if this was the
real trailer i feel like we will be
screwed because there's no computer with
a dvd drive anymore so this would be
like troublesome
anyway i can't tell you how excited we
all are about sonic 2 so many incredible
people are in this movie we got james
marsden tikka sumter colleen
o'shaughnessy as tails
idris elba as knuckles
and of course the legend jim carrey as
dr robotnik
now jim has actually sent a very special
video over to say hello to all of you
and
you guys are in luck because i have the
video with me right here
oh a call back i'm happy just kidding
this is blank still let's roll the video
jim what do you say
hello everyone and hello ben
i'm sorry i couldn't be there with you
but i look forward to meeting all of
your avatars in the metaverse
where we can really get to know each
other
hey before you see this exciting new
sonic trailer i'd like to pass on a word
of advice that my scottish grandfather
gave to me when i was just a boy he said
son
don't grade it in the grinder
don't do it son don't grade it in the
grinder boy
grade it
by all means create it till the cows
come home
but don't create it in the grinder
then to drive the point home he put his
hands around my neck and he squeezed
real hard he said go do it son
dude
and the grinder are you lost into me boy
are you last
wow yeah
inspiring words
thank you jim you know i think we all
needed to hear that
yeah take it in if you need to good
great okay here we go thank you again
for continuing to support the blue blur
and it is my honor to present to you the
trailer for sonic the hedgehog 2 enjoy
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
[Music]
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
[Music]
hopefully not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't too bad
[Music]
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
[Music]
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
oh